all right guys before we get into the
episode i just want to give a quick
shout out to our sponsor
third love which is a very very perfect
bra that i always wear and i always brag
about it because
i genuinely only wear these bras they're
so comfortable
you can find your own bra by taking the
fitting room quiz it's a simple
quiz that factors in size brush shape
and the current fitting issues that you
have with your bra and your personal
style
so you can treat yourself with something
that fits like it was made
just for you with third love go to
thirdlove.com
big mood now to get 20 off your first
purchase that's
thirdlove.com big mood for 20
off today
hello everyone and welcome back to big
moon
[Music]
podcasts
they were doing a sex episode today yeah
oh yeah at first i was like we are so
annoying but then i thought
it's okay we can be annoying for a
second yeah um what did girls talk about
sex
[Laughter]
i found this article on buzzfeed and i
wanted us to react to it
because i feel like we have a lot of fun
when we talk about the shitty parts of
sex
and that's exactly this article here it
says that people are sharing the
terrible parts of sex we don't usually
talk about
damn it i wanted to take a shot before
this episode just to loosen up and have
fun you should
get it these are can we fly in some
tequila please these are can we fly some
tequila producers
please thank you we got to loosen up
gina's lips
close my lips up yeah which ones yeah i
was about to say i'm
on my own last night in my house and i
got really drunk
on accident like more drunk than i did i
saw your story
more drunk than i intended to be and i
was like well
okay so i basically couldn't sleep
because i was so drunk i know what
everyone did yesterday
like tiff was at disneyland yeah and
jess was getting drunk alone having a
dance party with
lady gaga cute gino is i don't know an
anime cartoon that's where she posts on
her story i don't
only post anime so i don't know what
you're doing but i'm like she's at home
i thought she'd probably jump too i like
the close friends thing where you're
like
you'll be like oh you can't wait for
this album they're like that album
[ __ ] sucks
to decide if that stays in or they'll
leave it
out here on the close friends one i was
gonna say i was about to take my mask
off and be my true self yeah yeah
not the fake [ __ ] that everyone sees
you okay over there
[Music]
is it blanco tequila it is blanco is it
just me
yeah are you all drinking i'm not
drinking i will take a shot yeah
i'm hosting so i'm just going to get
more slurry as i start reading these
yeah
okay um i haven't actually read through
all these i when i first opened i
scrolled through a couple and i was like
these look funny so i have no idea
really what's on this list
but i'm just going to start from the
bottom whoa from the bottom now right
here
okay i like being a bottle no okay the
last one's kind of a joke so this is the
shitty things about sex
this is oh yeah so just because we got
way [ __ ] off topic for a minute
people are sharing the terrible parts of
sex we don't usually talk about
right i feel like we do that yeah we
have done that yeah
um but so let's see let's see if they
could get us yeah yeah yeah
um so i'll just start at the top
actually so we i think it it kind of
escalates
a bed that makes more noise than the
person you're having yeah i hate that
yeah
we got hardwood floors and when it was
carpet like the bed stayed in place
but then the hardwood floor is like it's
just like hitting the wall and i'm like
it took me all the way out
he's moving the belt yeah
i believe it because you know we were in
that cabin someone was having sex i'm
pretty sure it was y'all it was
steve it was like so heavy dude i
thought he was stopping
up i thought you were getting your ass
beat yeah i was like oh this is
a big marriage and then he's over here
[ __ ] beating her ass
my room was right next to theirs and i
basically had to be like i was like that
little kid that didn't want to hear that
yeah
you wanted to hear you're a voyeuristic
and i thought someone was stomping up
the stairs
it was a wood frame house yeah and it
was really old we were trying to be
i thought it was tiff in case because it
it shook the whole house so i thought it
was coming from the ceiling and they
were on the top floor but
the next morning tip was like yeah the
snow on the top of the house fell off
the roof
like a whole shelf
oh yeah because it was an a-frame house
yeah it was yeah
so yeah but yeah i've i've definitely
had instances where i was having sex and
i kind of like kind of almost instantly
you realize oh there's no
real chemistry here and then you just
kind of notice everything yeah
every everything about the environment
is just like
magnificent
[Laughter]
or like boring sex where um like i'm
doing my grocery list in my head i'm
like oh [ __ ] i still need to get paper
towels and
oh geez oh should i get i can get
laundry quarters when i go to the
grocery store
totally check out it's a good it's a
good amount of time to like
you know plan some things out yeah um
it's funny you know
don't be boring in bed and uh you know
make sure you have chemistry this is the
lesson there
well i mean and get the good furniture
yeah that's the lesson because i was
gonna ask you like how have you solved
that now
oh we haven't oh we we pulled it really
far away from the wall
you look in the middle of the room and
then slowly
he slides you through the wall because
there's an area rug underneath and i
think it was like
because there's no rug mat because we
had carpet before so i think like it was
sliding under the area
you need to get that like kind of sticky
yeah yeah did you buy it i
haven't bought it yet i like to imagine
that they move their bed in the middle
of room for sex and then
like they have to finish by the time it
hits the wall like it's a golden game
like steve's like come on honey we're
like this close to the wall street are
we gonna do this thing i've got four
thrust lives
do we make it
they measure it every time like hey new
record
we did it honey that's too good he's
like can we do a quickie and then he
only pulls the bed back three inches
yeah right three thrusts we're like how
do you want to do a whole long thing
they pull it all the way to the other
wall
they go to the
[Laughter]
every step of the sounds we heard at
that cabin i would not
doubt it you could get it up the stairs
i probably heard them coming
and i was like you know what good for
you guys that was a good night good for
you i did a strip teases
i was very drunk i was very drunk i'm
very dry
i was like you're a kid i was watching
cartoons sleeping in a bunk bed
all right covering my ears
why does every airbnb have a [ __ ]
bunk bed i know every airbnb
does that
um someone said having to stop abruptly
because your boyfriend accidentally
slapped his nuts when he tried to slap
your ass
that's never happened it's more like
having to stop abruptly
because his dick breaks you know like we
land on it wrong
i've definitely almost broken a deck a
few times or like when they accidentally
slip out because they thrust too hard
and kind of angles yes
actually like they had to go to the
hospital because
and then he actually had to get
circumcised oh my gosh once like
it slipped and then she landed wrong and
there was just blood everywhere it was
[ __ ] crazy holy [ __ ] and he actually
had to get circumcised after that
because it tore his
his force i can't understand why he
would have to get circumcised that's
some [ __ ]
i didn't go to the hospital after sex
i remember that sometimes you get [ __ ]
into a nightstand
oh yeah that you have to stop abruptly
and you get your face
cut your lip open and you're gonna just
get a cool a scar yeah out of your nose
yeah i don't know about that one i don't
know as awkward
has ever slapped his nuts when trying to
slap your ass yeah which position is
that
doggy
what's the one where like your legs are
on top of his shoulders wearing
missionaries
missionary yeah that's just like being
folded in half yeah folded right yeah
like maybe then he could try to slap her
ass and then he accidentally gets his
nuts
i'm trying to think about this oh he's
trying to slap your ass and he hits his
nuts yeah yeah
that's what this they're hitting a
comment style he tried to slap you like
a race horse from behind
and he slapped his balls instead no
hand-eye coordination
what is happening no i'm thinking like
so when you thrust
out right and then her ass is like there
right in front of you
and you go back in he's like thrusting
the balls hit the ass at the same time
the hand hits the ass
so it's like a swing and pit i don't
know i have no clue this girl is like
goes live that's a one-off story for you
not really no one no one relates no
liar july no one's like oh [ __ ] yeah
that happens all the time right because
what if it's not a girl
like what are the other positions that
could this could happen with like
a guy and guy i don't know i guess oh
man there's a lot of balls happening
with two guys
that could have wonder if guys who are
gay
having sex with other guys they slap
butts and they accidentally smack a ball
that they i think that's what tiff was
saying yeah yeah
just wondering yeah that could be that's
a scenario that works
with physics for me guys taking a shot
on an empty stomach is just [ __ ]
gina's gone just learn her words good
night
what is inside your body um just lots of
coffee
yeah and that's all and apparently all
your organs being
like having signs like they're homeless
they're begging for nutrients like
will work for broccoli at this point the
tequila's nutrients for them like yes
please
oh god anything at this point so that
made from a plant it's made from a plant
everywhere
thankful for what we got yeah freshen it
up
liver [ __ ] off yeah we love you but
you're gonna die early
yeah um this next comment says if you're
like me you sweat fairly easily so being
on top means i'm dripping from my face
and usually it's landing in or around my
girlfriend's eyes and mouth
i've had that one we've talked about a
sweat band but i'm not sure it would
increase
passion or cause laughter
snaps back to the forehead let's do this
and then just a sweat band
but now i'm in i'm imagining uh curly
hair like 80s
oh yeah and then the curly hair why is
it that the guys with the curly hair
sweat more than the guys
off the curl this was an episode of sex
in the city though
charlotte's husband oh really and they
actually ended up turning around more i
think oh
crazy i remember a guy was on top of me
once it was summer and we were poor we
didn't have
uh air conditioning he would sweat on
top of me and she's like sometimes it
drips in your eyes and your mouth
yeah like yeah this is not i did it once
with the guy
like and i but i didn't love him like it
was just like supposed to be a one night
thing
so i think i gotta like really like have
feelings for that to be right
okay right yeah i had sex with a dude
once too and it was just a one time
kind of thing in high school and same
thing it was
summertime he was sweating a lot and
i remember like because i like rubbing
his back when he's on
sweating greasy nasty
i was like totally what do you do at
that point because i would be like okay
can we stop and then i would just take a
pillow and kind of dab
no way off his face that would just ruin
the mood
you can be supposed to i was i was a
teenager i was [ __ ] horny like
who cares yeah whatever i think when
you're a teenager it doesn't matter my
my first boyfriend was sweaty
but like i don't know we were young and
i didn't know any difference like
you're like oh i guess i just get rained
on with sweat i also loved him so
and you can be like a those coaches in
the boxing corner she's like
scared that's how it works
there's a pillow right next to you you
could just take it and be like dab the
face a couple of times
dab the chest it's so big you just
squeeze it between you because you look
quick
very sweaty we just grab the sheet the
sheets attached to the bed
no you could just i mean the other
sheets the flat sheet yeah that one i
remember i dropped a sweat line in my
mouth i didn't like that very much
i don't like that at all i think
honestly though if i'm really
in the middle of it i won't notice but
if i'm kind of
out of it like you said like kind of not
really into it or
i checked out or something it'll
definitely gross me out more than if i'm
like super into them i just request
doggy style
has a girl ever sweat have you ever
sweat during sex not like that i don't
drip when i sweat i barely sweat
yeah i barely sweat too i think the
sweatiest i've ever remember getting is
just kind of in the vag area where it
just gets so
moisty where like then your lower pelvic
area starts getting kind of wet
your inner thigh cracks the sidecraft
yeah yeah butt crack maybe a little
sweaty but
yeah under boob sweat a little bit yeah
my boobs don't
fold so no oh yeah yeah i don't i mean
you don't even get the little one the
little drips barely shout out to the
fake boobs let's go
yeah you have like titty armpits so
[ __ ] yeah actually i one time actually
did put some deodorant under my boobs
does that work this is
too crazy it did work oh okay because i
just figured that
deodorant was like four armpits skin so
i don't know if it would work on boob
skin
i remember i went to florida for the
first time and i felt something like
tickle down i thought a bug
fall down it was a sweat trip it was a
sweatshirt i was like holy [ __ ] titties
what's the real thing i had to shove a
pic this was during a drift racing
competition where i had to take pictures
with fans and stuff oh i just showed
like a paper towel in between my
cleavage yeah i think
gina stuff's her bra
those fake boobies are stuffed with
tissue i took a picture with her and i
saw the stuffing
out no that's true though that's why i
can't i can't
not wear some sort of bra like that one
time i put deodorant under was because i
was wearing something
like a type of shirt that i didn't need
to wear for like yeah
i could wear it without a bra and just
having that fold
immediately is like in the skin contact
yeah i just sweat that happens to me
when i go
panties i feel like i get a lot more
thigh sweat
like yeah bro you know you guys you guys
know how like i only i
exclusively only wear sticky bras yes
when it's sweaty it unsticks
yeah so i've had to catch my bra
sometimes yeah
yeah a [ __ ] fish fell out like a
picture
a cutlet
okay there's another one here uh when
everything isn't wet yet
and a guy tries to jam his penis into
your vagina and the labia goes along for
a very
painful dry ride yeah i [ __ ]
feel that one yeah that curtain gets
caught in the way and she goes with it
ouch you have to like go down there and
pry it out you have to like get it
and then
[Laughter]
i mean i don't have no lips i it doesn't
get dragged in it's so short and small
and it's not there i don't know
be normal gina fine yeah it gets dragged
in there
and then has it ever happened to you
guys too like where your perineum
gets like slit a little bit yes yes it
hurts
so much from it being dry yeah so mine's
not the lips but the
like clitoral hood kind of gets dragged
in there
have y'all ever had such like friction
that it makes one of your [ __ ] lips
swell and you sit down that's happening
the [ __ ] it sucks
because the friction of it just yeah and
it swells up and it hurts and you have
to ice it
actually with my ex i i started feeling
i
feel like my body was rejecting him so
hard that i started feeling like i was
allergic to him
because every time after every time we
would have sex i would my [ __ ] would get
so swollen yeah it was so it's pretty
common i think like the rug burn type of
feeling
is that like what you're talking about
yeah so constant rug burn to the point
where it swells up
and it's like and then after you're done
having sex it feels like
like um like that the sound that wants
to come out of my mouth it's like
yeah it's like it hurts like you want to
sit on an ice cube
yes it's very interesting because yeah
after a while
like in a relationship when you're not
in it anymore you're not in love you
don't care anymore it actually hurts
yeah your body rejects it your body
rejects your vagina it will
just it's kind of like having um like
you know
with boners when it's soft like it's the
vagina version of that
exactly yeah like it starts hurting
actually internally too
it's just all right that's how i know
i'm checked out this relationship
exactly yeah i had sex with a guy
once and the first time it felt good but
then yeah the second time i went back
it hurt and i was like yeah this is this
is definitely not
crazy however vagina does that yeah the
vagina trying to stop it
it's like your lips are trying to close
the door yeah but then they [ __ ] get
caught and they get dragged in they're
like hey [ __ ] no
yeah sometimes they pick the wrong guy
too like the your brain's like
no this person's toxic it's no good the
vagina's like no no
yeah we need him we want him to
choose him yeah she's a dumb she's a
dumb
picker look at this guy he's an
accountant he has a good job
he has blonde hair and blue eyes excuse
me really basic as a human
from texas my vagina would not reject
you jess
thank you gina i like that vagina's in
your name
vagina yes vegina i am the the the
ambassador of vaginas
the ambassador the vagina ambassador
gina right guys now it's time to shout
out our sponsor
third love we love sirloin my most
favorite bra
i'm currently wearing their 24 7 pima
cotton
t-shirt bra it has like a band at the
bottom and it's just like it just it's
the most comfortable for me the ones
with the band at the bottom not the
underwire yeah
they're really strong no well this one
does have a wire but it's like another
i mean you have the big ass titties so
you kind of always need an underwear but
i have a teeny tiny one so
yeah but see the reason why third love
is so amazing and why
i personally highly recommend it is
because they find
the perfect bra for your boobies because
everyone has different
types of boobies like size shapes
different needs
exactly chart too you can look at it and
like look at yours in the mirror and see
which ones you are which ones you want
yeah exactly
so you can take the fitting room quiz
and it's a simple quiz that factors in
the size the breast shape the current
fitting issues that you have with your
bra
and your personal style to find the
perfect bras and underwear for you
no more awkward dressing room moments
like when they're like measuring for you
or whatever you know your own body
better than anyone right
so take the fitting room quiz from the
comfort of your own
home you can get the level of fit and
comfort you deserve with their love bras
underwear and loungewear
find your new favorite everyday
essentials from loungewear to their
number
number one rated 24 7 classic t-shirt
bra which i also own by the way i own
you have all their brothers you have
like three or four years
yeah so uh they also they stand behind
their products so if you don't love it
you can exchange
and return for free the return process
is really easy because i had to go
down one half cup size and it was it
like the return one got to me faster
than i could mail out the one that i
needed to exchange it was super easy
yeah that's awesome
so treat yourself with something that
fits like it was made just for you with
third love go to thirdlove.com
big mood now to get 20 off your first
purchase that's
thirdlove.com big mood for 20
off today and please use your code it
lets them know
that we sent you and you get to support
our show
and we don't just take care of our women
in this podcast we're taking care of our
men too
it's been a long quarantine and you know
what you need in a long quarantine
because you can't see each other
dick introducing
you guys are like what this is for my
guys out there
bluechu is a unique online service that
delivers the same active ingredients as
viagra and cialis but in a chewable form
and at a fraction of the cost that means
we're making your wiener hard
for cheaper for cheaper bluetooth
tablets help men achieve
harder and stronger erections to combat
all forms of erectile dysfunction
bluetooth is an online prescription
service so no visits to the doctor's
office no awkward conversations and no
waiting in line at the pharmacy and it
ships right to your door in a discrete
package
the process is simple sign up at
bluechew.com consult with one of their
licensed medical providers
and once you're approved you'll receive
your prescription within days
the best part is all done online you've
got no one touching your weiner at the
doctor's office
blue chews licensed medical providers
work with you to find the right
ingredients and strength for your
prescription
so if you can benefit from extra
confidence when it comes time to perform
visit bluetooth.com for more details and
important safety information
and we've got a special deal for our
listeners try bluetooth
free wow fred
when you use our promo code big mood at
checkout just pay five dollars shipping
that's all
if you even get five dollars and you got
other things to worry about that
shouldn't be getting dig
down if you don't got five dollars yeah
if you're if you're getting digged down
without five dollars
you must have a really good personality
that's bluechew.com promo code big mood
to receive your first month
free we thank bluechu for sponsoring
this podcast
how does the vagina ambassador feel
about this one the autozone smell after
doing it with a condom on
oh right that's a burst get in the zone
that's all i've smelt and tasted for
food wise
for the past like three months like
condoms
yeah how [ __ ] hilarious that is is
that
disgusting i find it hilarious i hate
fun that you smell and taste condom all
the time now because of coped
yeah is it still the case or has it gone
it's gonna it's like faded but there's
still
certain foods that it's like whoa it's
not gone oh no yeah but
the list of foods has gone down um let's
see the other night we were
yeah like onions for sure like 100
yeah and steve was making beef i think
beef is like that
um before it was all meats but now i
think it's just
beef and onions and uh
yeah i don't know if any of you heard of
this but yeah everything i smelled and
ate
tasted like tasted and smelled like
condoms like latex that latex like
chemically ew autozone i know what that
you know like when
the when you're having sex and then he
wants you to put it in your mouth
and then he takes the condom off and
then it tastes like
powder yes rubber it's like powder but
also it's like
bitter it's bitter and then it's also
like kind of um
what's the term like when you have
plastic over skin the skin
texture changes oh yeah yeah it's like
almost like like
waterlogged a little because it's just
like it's i don't know it's hard to
explain it's
it's it doesn't do good things for a
penis to have a condom on even though it
makes sex safe but i feel like i feel
like any the girls in the gays that have
had to suck dick after taking off the
condom should get a nobel peace prize
that is an american that's something you
do when you're young i feel like and
then as you get older you're like i'm
not [ __ ] putting that in my mouth
you're on the front line yeah yeah
exactly i'm not doing that again
25 you're on the front line yeah yeah as
brave as our troops man
i'm telling you or have you ever sucked
a dick with a condom on
no what's important that what about
those flavored condoms have you guys
ever done that i haven't seen
ass i've never done it lube yeah
how was that not that great oh my god
you know what would be good do you
remember that candy that uh
used to be out when we were younger it
was just like a tube of like cherry
jelly
yeah yeah i feel like that would
probably taste way better than the loot
but
but it's got actual sugar in it so i
don't think you should have sex with it
speaking of it
but you could just put it on a deck
speaking of have you ever yes like you
walk home from school
you don't know what that smell is but
when you grow older that's it there's
that tree in the spring they bloom
flowers it smells like [ __ ]
the sperm trees oh i've heard of that
but i uh yeah i've never seen this
is it they talk about it here in la la
but i i don't think we have those in
texas
yeah there's a treat that smells like
what's it called because i
yeah i've heard about it but i i never
experienced
yeah i mean it's 2021 though i don't
understand why condoms don't smell and
taste better
true like if we're going to mars and
[ __ ] like can't we
figure that out because straight males
dominate
products and industries don't they want
their dick sucked though like
make it taste better like if we give you
no other option then
that you have to do it that way no
excuse what about female condoms have
you ever tried those and
i've never seen one i've never seen any
of them either well actually no i saw
shan on her stories i think
i'd like show one but i've never even
buy them i've never seen them
in stores yeah i don't know weird they
have to be available
yeah but i'm like no one's really using
that probably and i wonder if it has
that same powdery latex
thing going on i don't think so because
guys are using them like putting their
mouths on them watch those taste like
really good yeah
they're like tastes like beef stew this
is pretty good
you could be down here which weirdly
tastes like condoms to me oh joe that's
right now
with your covered mouth yeah also why
the [ __ ] did we have glow-in-the-dark
condoms
yeah what's going on here so you can
find one of those so the dick can find
the whole
fun i haven't got you've gone in the
dark i've never seen i mean like i've
seen like i heard about it like on tv
and stuff or like in high school you're
like oh you guys you really glued
our condoms like why the [ __ ] do we have
those
ravers
[ __ ] um all right here's another one
getting fingered by someone who did not
cut their fingernails nikki i know that
you are not down
strictly because of this reason it
doesn't matter how short the fingernails
are
i don't ever notice i don't think i've
ever had a guy
with long fingernails just the thought
of it freaks me out i like lots of
fingers inside me if you can just shove
a bunch of fingers and that'd be dope
because it's cause it's cool
you have to peel your nails off yeah but
if you have long nails
imagine getting scratched up in there
yeah because people don't know this but
your vagina doesn't feel like
it doesn't feel that yeah but it feels
the pressure yeah it doesn't feel the
sharpness of it but it feels the
pressure
and like like the nails is scraping yeah
my vaginal walls scares the [ __ ] out and
then like guys get so excited when they
think they're pleasurable
so they start going faster and you're
just like yeah no yeah
that's definitely a problem i i don't
think i've ever noticed a dude's nails
being long but it reminds me of
me with my nails and me using
that um i forgot what it's called but
it's like a circular
kind of thing that you stick up in there
when you're you have your period
and you're able to have some yeah all
the cuppy thingies
it's not a diva yeah but it's like a
flat one it sits right underneath
i think it's called flex or something
flex cup
it's not a cup it's a disc yeah it's
like a disc thing yeah
and so you're supposed to like put it in
and like it sits oh your
vagina and no no hold on so it's easy to
put in
yeah and i just like you gotta put your
finger to like put it
in the position behind your pelvic bone
but to take it out mm-hmm
i [ __ ] scrape up in there i needed it
because i would have been there and get
it out yeah i would have my
my long ass nails and i'm like oh yeah i
have to go in there and like [ __ ]
find the edge of it and then like
that's why i can't do period cups either
yeah yeah i don't want to put i don't
want any fingers in there yeah
no and if you scratch it period cups and
if you do scratch it
you can't tell it's just the thought of
it it's just
yeah i couldn't do the cups for a while
like i just i tried it can do it
you anyways um here's another one having
to push pets away
that just won't get off the bed and sit
there staring at you
sometimes they come over and try to
smell yeah you know we always kick out
our cats before we have sex
we always kick them out we forget we get
wrapped up at the moment
and then there's a cat like trying to
try to purge
just like pawing your face
my oldest he's he kind of he's very
intuitive on when we're done but
sometimes we're like still fooling
around and he thinks we're done he'll
jump up he's like
okay i heard you guys are done the
slamming part is over so they're
actually done
yeah but then we're like no no no no and
he gets very cuddly
so like he's it's really hard to push
him away that's cute do you feel bad and
you're like
trying to focus on steve but then you're
like oh but the kitty's doing such a
cute little thing right now
yeah and he's like that too he's like i
know he's cute but like
okay he's really cute my cat doesn't
give a [ __ ]
like he just sits there he's like again
oh god damn it all right
he just sleeps on the right sleep yeah i
don't i'm trying to recall if i've ever
had an issue with pets but i think most
of the guys i've been with don't
have not had pets what about your dogs
maddie and sophie
i think usually i'm at the guy's house
but if i do happen to be at mine then i
just
the dogs are go out immediately first
into the living room
yeah i've had that uh when you're like
when we're doing a missionary style
because i dated a guy with a dog and
like missionary style the dog kind of
sneaks up and just oh cold nose right
near my butthole oh
geez get him out please please he's like
smells like fish or like or like you
know i'm in the middle of a second dick
and the dog comes over he's like what's
this i'm like no no hold on i'm going to
wait like right near me like hey can i
eat that too you're like no no
like are there troubles yeah there must
be treats over here right no it just it
freaks me out because like my cats
i don't know it might be weird or
whatever but like i feel like
they know what's going on and there
there's a soul in that
they're like we [ __ ] we don't kind of
like it's kind of like having you guys
over and being cool with having sex with
you guys there
like it's no like you guys are out there
too
aware that you're [ __ ] and you don't
like that they're aware so you feel
guilty or something i just feel weird
it's
it says this like having an audience
yeah it's like having two humans in the
room
they have a soul they know what's
happening they know what's happening
do you feel like it's the same for dogs
same
because dogs are just like what's this
yeah no
same like no matter what pets like even
when back when we had pixel with us
and the snake like i would you think the
snake i would not have sex with
the snake in the room really i'm like
get out
this wasn't giving a [ __ ] about it was
just rejecting a little yeah
yeah you're the voyeurism the voyeurism
yeah
onto a snake into a snake like this
snake's watching me
it's a paranoia she's laying there on
the bed just looking at the snake while
i know where that's coming from
but it's going to go okay okay i know
where it's kind of got it got it
triggered yeah okay okay well we can go
ahead and try to move on yeah let's move
on
let's move on to the next one the fart
noises that your bodies make when you're
doing it
[Music]
if a guy ever stops or even just the
stomach farts i hate the stomach farts
it makes me laugh every time because
yeah that's why that's the only good
thing about two people being in shape
because there's not really any fat to
suctiony so like if you're you've got
two hard bodies going on you're not
gonna get that you know
my husband's a never nude so he always
has a t-shirt on yeah there you go my
husband
he just walked in did you realize that
was me earlier in the car
i was talking i was just talking about
how i don't get weird 40 sounds with
your stomach because you wear a t-shirt
and
sex oh wait sex in a t-shirt because
he's a never nude yeah
wait doesn't the shirt kind of get
caught up in there sometimes sometimes i
lift it a little
cause we always are we're like here this
is restricting just [ __ ]
take it off steve by the way loves when
i talk about him on this show he loves
it he can't wait for me to
if any guy ever gets bothered by who you
made a little 40 noise like shut the
[ __ ] up dude are you 12.
real men keep going i've never had a guy
be bothered no
no i think it's probably an actual fart
and it smells
i think i think like i have giggled in
the bedroom because
because i'm the one giggling then he'll
giggle oh i say but i just like i can't
not acknowledge it or laugh at it or
whatever but we keep going
oh i just don't acknowledge it at all
it's like this is what happens i think
it depends now it depends on the
on the mood like if i kind of have a
bantery relationship with the guy
and if a loud [ __ ] queef escapes
i'm gonna be like yo that was nuts oh my
god
i can't not acknowledge it but if it's
someone i kind of don't really know i'm
just like wow that happened
you know it's like an awkward elevator
yeah killing
she looks like she goes you did it
[Laughter]
[ __ ] up in there i'm like why are you
filling my [ __ ] with air instead of
dick
anyway no no i think i think the stomach
ones are the funny ones for me because
you're like
he'll be hitting it right like usually
when they're hitting it right the
stomach starts farting oh like
you know like that's how you know
they're hitting it right because the
stomach starts farting
that's true or like the liquid the
liquid inside your stomach
washing around that's the way yeah i get
so embarrassed by it
every time he pushes it's like
[ __ ] my tacos are just calling me out
right now
um okay this one's talking about i guess
after you know
a guy might stick a little thumb little
finger towards the butthole area you
know then
he's talking about trying to gracefully
avoid touching the other body areas with
the butt finger
that's nice that's considerate what is
considered yeah i mean if you're a real
man i think you'll just
you know
no i just think that um i don't know
there's a lot of fluids going on
yeah but not [ __ ] yeah we don't need a
poopy thumb
suck no well you're telling me you're
gonna suck a dick after it's been inside
your butt
no exactly yeah that's when if it went
all the way inside my butt that's
different if it
what do you mean i don't know if you
pressed against my butthole it could be
feces on the thumbnail
i don't know i don't know i don't know
about the butt finger
nope so i guess butterfly so what if i
mean i guess we got to give the guys a
little bit of credit because if they do
the butt finger then they gotta like
deal with it for the rest of the time
and have that on their mind yeah yeah
touch your titties with it yeah that's
why you need to tell upon your pet then
for the sweat
one [ __ ] yeah exactly just wipe them
off
should we put in our mouth like when the
dick's all cheesy or crusty you've i
know you've sucked a dick that's not
been very clean before
yeah my husband has a very clean dick a
very you don't get the choice
you always get a clean dish but i know
we've had a cheesy dick
once or twice in our life so what's the
difference it's all bacteria
well there is a difference because urine
is not as disgusting as feces
yes yeah sure agree yeah i guess i'm
remember the would you rathers okay yeah
yeah we all picked pee pee i did pick me
up
i did i did i picked i don't know yeah
you picked something yeah i love god
um the waddle to the bathroom afterward
with one hand cupped
over your badge uh the water can't
really like
my [ __ ] so tight i can't really
i'm so sick of your time
[Applause]
it's the truth though plus we're trying
to yeah suck the semen in
trying to have yeah you kind of like do
you late different labels no but
actually
so nah what do you do well we haven't
been trying lately but
um i don't know like we just after sex i
just walk to the bathroom and pee
i don't relax it like do you relax
vagina and then i fall out my napkin um
no it doesn't fall out i don't know what
i mean it comes out like throughout the
week i feel like yeah i was gonna
ask that so yeah so like with us like i
am
he's making a face but that's what
happened sorry baby that's life here
he's up there for several days yeah
he's proud right so you get it yeah i
totally get it so like i'm trying to
keep it in
and i do do the when you stand up it's
not going to stay in
no it does it does so it does stay in
yeah but then sometimes like if i
if i'm like sitting down or i'll stand
up and i
relax a little bit it will come out a
little bit
you can feel like it's like a lookie
like you're trying to hold it during the
like when you weren't expecting it like
throughout the day like you're doing
laundry and then you're like oh there's
always
yeah there's always an afterburn i get
the after burp too but usually right
after
there's definitely the initial like no
i'm squeezing
and then trying to pee do you oh i don't
know if you try to keep it in but
for me i'm trying to still keep it in
not relaxing anything so when i'm peeing
i'm like yeah yeah it's like slowly
letting my pee out because i'm not
trying to release the
the hold mm-hmm it's really it's a
difficult task wow
i this is a life i've never lived yeah i
cup it with a napkin wallet to the
bathroom and get it out sometimes i'll
sit to you
huh yeah i always keep wet wipes and
stuff near the bed and like because i
know if we're gonna get down
yeah i keep tissues by my beds both
nightstands have tissues and then i lay
in the bathtub
and then have the faucet fall directly
into a lot of work to wash it all out
really wow you do all that yeah that's
crazy getting pregnant i do the uh
that's not gonna stop you from getting
pregnant i know but it's just i like to
get it right
this is gonna come out not for me she's
like it's worked so fast it's awesome
it's gonna help first of all but the
more way to not get pregnant
it's going to help first of all a little
bit because i want to get it out but
also because the main reason is
come throws off my ph it's just so bad
so i try to get that [ __ ] out
immediately yeah yeah and then like when
you stand up afterwards all the water
rushes out of your vagina
yeah it's still i think i don't think a
dermatologist or
a gynecologist would agree with um yeah
it could make sure
douche that you're doing yeah i mean
it's just water
you know maybe if you uh have
i don't know distilled water that
doesn't have germs in it i don't know
why are you supposed to do like saline
waters
for your hard la mineral water oh yeah
ouch
who freaking knows going to get a
calcite in there
calcified calcium deposits
fluoride
your third eye is closed from all that
[ __ ] fluoride up your vagina
attitude oh my god
thank you attitude for sponsoring the
show these are my favorite shows i never
want to sleep in anything ever
seriously they're like they're on the
more luxury end
but spend the dollar it is one thousand
percent worth it
it's so comfortable like game changer
for your sleep i'm not kidding and i
think they have
i feel like a queen in that they have a
thing where you could if you don't like
it you can return it but like you're not
going to return it because it's so
freaking good i think they never get
returns
i don't think they should i don't think
they should i'm like i am judging the
people that return i honestly
never gotten a return so the dirty
little not so dirty secret about the
bedding aisle is that while cotton might
be the most popular fabric for sheets
duvets and pillowcases it's also the
most damaging to our planet
that's why i'm thrilled to introduce you
to attitude i freaking love attitude
it's made with like
uh organic 100 organic bamboo fr
fabric which has this like silky but
also
really soft like feathery soft texture
that's similar to silk but not
as slippery as it's also like like it
has like a heavy-ness
feature to it yeah or it's not like like
weighing down on you but it's like
i just feel so good and you're just like
enveloped in like the warmest little
cocoon
and also if you sweat at night it has a
cooling part to it too so whether you
want to be warm or cold it's got your
back
it delivers unparalleled comfort that
actually feels better than cotton i 100
agree with that
and unlike cotton which consumes massive
amounts of water energy and chemicals
during projection
production attitude uses organic bamboo
the most resource efficient plant on the
planet their passion is to provide the
best quality sleep in the most
sustainable way attitudes organic bamboo
fabrics are temperature regulating
hypoallergenic
antibacterial and toxin free okay no
excuses
you could try attitude betting for 30
nights and if you're not completely
satisfied you can return it for a full
refund
or just give it to me if you don't want
it yeah seriously just yeah i'll give
you
the money but please don't leave stains
that's weird come on man
i don't even care i'll take it with
things i can love these sheets
right now you can get 20 off your order
plus free shipping when you visit
etitude.com
mood and enter promo code mood remember
that's edited as an
eco attitude order today for free
shipping and 20
off your order at attitude.com mood
promo code
mood mood yes this episode is also
brought to you by apostrophe a
prescription skin care company for
people that are ready to take their acne
seriously prescription acne treatments
really work but it can be kind of hard
to get you have to take time off work go
see a doctor sit in line at the pharmacy
for medications
well you know what not anymore
apostrophe makes it easy to see a
board-certified dermatologist online
you'll get treated immediately and your
medications will be delivered directly
to your home
simply fill out apostrophe's online
questionnaire about your skin concerns
and medical history then just snap a few
selfies
the dermatologist will get back to you
with a customized treatment plan
tailored
just for your skin the best part is
apostrophe offers topical
and oral medications so you can treat it
from the outside and the inside and you
know it's actually going to work
it's not just some made up bs maybe this
will work
no this is proven results apostrophe
treats acne and they can also help hit
your skin care goals like reducing
redness wrinkles and even dark spots
if you want to get 15 off your first
visit with a board certified
dermatologist go to apostrophe.com
big mood and use our code big mood this
is only available to our listeners
to get started go to com slash big
apostrophe.com
click on begin visit and then use the
code big mood at sign up and you'll get
15
off your dermatology visit that's
a-p-o-s-t-r-o-p-h-e
apostrophe dot com slash big mood and
use the code big mood to get your
dermatology visit for 15
off we thank apostrophe for sponsoring
the podcast
all right here's another one taking a
little too long to finish and then
feeling embarrassed and then the more
you think about it the harder it is to
finish
yes sounds like a guy problem when i was
younger maybe really
yeah usually to me you don't ever feel
special to finish
oh i never i don't usually finish oh oh
i got me something cool with like i had
fun this was
great i'm glad you finished that's it
that's where i get my pleasure
really it depends on the activity if
it's just straight sex then i'm
cool with that but then if it's oral
like like we came here
to play like we are committed to this
and if i don't if i think i'm too
distracted then i'm like
just go straight to the sex yeah i'll be
like stop i'm not it's not happening
don't waste your time
but yeah i i feel a lot that pressure
to like finish or something i think when
it's a stranger or like someone a new
relationship emotionally
yeah for sure i think there's a lot of
communication with like a long-term
relationship though like yeah
like i feel like we found a group where
i know
he knows exactly where how long he could
he chooses when i come basically
yeah i don't need someone what a flex
yeah yeah
it's gotten honed over the years and
like it's down to a science now no one
could ever choose when i come
never i don't know how you figured that
out steve green
steve green he's a [ __ ] that's why they
call him the [ __ ] master
oh i forgot yeah he's holding a cue card
for me to read
but i'm like tiff i don't need to orgasm
my pleasure is i get off on seeing you
come
yeah yeah so i don't need to you know
orgasm every time
and like on some days i'm like i don't
really feel like coming today i just
want youtube yes
yeah do you like it better though like
if you have sex
after coming like if he goes down on me
first and i come and then we have sex i
don't really need to come again during
sex
it feels just ten times better though
like everything's so much more sensitive
and like more receptive i'm like
do you think that you don't really need
to come or you're just you know how
difficult it is for
sex with a man penis and vagina to make
you come so you're like uh it's fine
don't i don't not worry
like is it is it like you don't really
need it because you've given up on it
being possible because
you haven't it hasn't come easy for you
or do you really genuinely don't like
orgasms
it's not that i don't like orgasms i
like them but i honestly feel like i get
off
more on him orgasming i know it takes a
long time for me and it's difficult
but i don't know i just i like
to see him happy more than so you're not
having sex for you
you're having sex to make and i like
yeah i don't know it's just
not a big deal for me and then you know
on days that i do decide to orgasm like
cool we get to both
orgasm together it's awesome but it's
not a big yeah because for me it's not
like
i can't or like that he can't make me
orgasm because similar
like sometimes he'll go down and then
i'll
end up coming and then i agree with what
nicky's saying like the sex afterwards
is amazing and it's
a completely different kind that makes
more sense because you already finished
yeah but just did not come at all you're
like oh it's fine but is that out of
exhaustion
or exasperation or is that because you
literally don't care about orgasm i feel
like
i'm satisfied already it's kind of like
having a delicious meal
and it's like do you have to have
dessert every time no but dessert's good
you like dessert but you don't have to
have it
yeah every meal it's not unsatisfying if
you
have sex and don't come yeah because
i've already
gotten my satisfaction from just having
sex already
i get it too because like with sex i
don't it's completely different oral
and like intercourse because with actual
sex
i just want him to [ __ ] the thoughts out
of my head sometimes i just need to get
grounded and so like when when he's
doing that he's like
that's enough of like that's enough of
like that's like
just as good as orgasm but also at the
same time too like um
it's not that i don't want to come at
all like there are times
like for the most part i like it when he
orgasms but i would also like it
sometimes too if you're like you know
what
let's focus on you today yeah make sure
this [ __ ] happens like if i'm in
early i dated some words for two months
and didn't even bother to ask or like
hey can i make you orgasm do you want me
to do something didn't care at all
wow that's a [ __ ] different story
[ __ ] that you know
because it's not like i don't want to at
all i do want to sometimes you know
just be considerate well just like the
fact that wasn't an option like what are
you
doing
yeah the fact that it wasn't an option
or you're not even capable that's
that's yeah because then like with me
and casey for example like they'll be
like practically every single time he
wants to
know if i want to come or not because
there's some times where i'm like
there's a [ __ ] animal inside of me
and i don't know what's happening but
we're [ __ ] until i come
three times and so we keep going but
most of the time though that doesn't
happen but but if it is gonna happen
though he
he's very open to the multiple sessions
that we
tend to have yeah yeah i like that he's
able to
come through accommodate he's able to do
requests exactly
even like like if they know me well
enough like this guy i did it for a long
time he's just like
do you want to come today i'm like i
don't really feel like he's that hard
yeah he's in discussion it's nice i like
the
the cadence of that yeah all right now
you want to come today
a little bit tired i'm lazy
there was a time though where like in
our relationship like earlier in our
relationship
where practically every single time that
we're having sex like we
we like using toys so he'll bust out a
toy and like be like
cool ready all right and then i would be
finishing every single time
yeah yeah so it definitely makes it
easier are there anything
are there things that aren't on this
list that you guys like personal things
that you feel
are awkward or people don't really talk
about
not awkward but then for me they're
during sex
i would have to always have like a towel
or a shirt to wipe because i get really
wet
and when you get really wet sometimes
it's too slippery and it just works
because i swear yeah so that we would
have to have like a towel nearby or
something and then it gets
annoying because it's like please don't
get on the sheets in the bed because
then you know like i don't want to deal
with this right now and i want to do
laundry
i don't want to do laundry so that kind
of sucks and you just have to layer
something down every time
my problem is i'm too wet if you don't
have to do the laundry if you just
open the sheets open the curtains the
sun will kill the bacteria and then you
could
like sleep on it for another i'm never
sleeping in your bed
i wash my sheets like every week and i
don't often have sex but
when i was in a relationship i was like
i'm not [ __ ] cleaning the sheets
every time we have sex yeah
that's ridiculous that's too many times
to do laundry but the sun
if the sun hits your bed it will kill
the bacteria i'm over here
pretend judging you but i'm way nasty
did you never i know you should say you
don't watch
seriously i wash my sheets way more than
you for sure
i wash my sheets very often but i feel
like it's out of necessity because
usually a cat has thrown up on
them during the week you just wait for a
cat to vomit yeah yeah
it happens at least once a week so
laundry day yeah they keep me on track
they really keep me on schedule
the shitty another bad thing is like
when you sleep on the wet spot
i usually make him sleep in the wet spot
like you cause you make the wet spot and
then you make himself that's why
getting a king-size bed has been
game-changing no one has to sleep on the
wet spot it's big enough like it's just
sits there in the center
you're good but like when you're in a
hotel with two beds like that's a bed
we're ruining yeah that's better
that's pretty cute yeah yeah you guys um
do you do period sex or are you anti
yeah real men do period sex yeah i mean
we've had period sex but
in your recent years i'm like i don't
want to deal with that have you ever
had someone that was like grossed out by
it no
no yeah i mean either i don't think if
they're grossed out by it they admit it
or like if they were grossed out by it
it was like when they were 17 yeah
quickly got old kids they don't know
yeah have you all had i mean i know
[ __ ] you but
sex injuries
injuries no i don't think i've ever been
injured i mean besides
oh waddling besides the being [ __ ]
into a nightstand um
you know when you're in high school
there's nowhere to have sex because like
you can't go to anyone's house and
parents are home and stuff
um so there was a lot of car sex
involved and usually
i would be on top because it's easier
than the diving on top
and using the seat or yes facing the
seat okay yeah
and where do your knees go so i always
sit double you sit anyway
and so that's kind of like w sit like
where you it's out to the side like this
your knees are together these are
together like this like this
no i'm saying how do you have sex facing
the car seat
yeah he's sitting in the car seat so i'm
w
can you okay yeah
all right like this yeah okay okay how
is that w
what does that mean that's the thumbnail
yeah the completely
feet go behind you anyway i got um the
seat belt was like
i guess rubbing into my rubbing into my
knee
area like or my skin and it like
created this huge wound i didn't realize
that was so in the moment i think i
still have like a scar from that
somewhere
yeah probably on the outside one of
these yeah like one of these
i feel like i have had an injury but i
can't remember so it might have been my
head
oh my god oh my god
that was a popsicle show you just opened
unlocked a memory for me i've definitely
had my head banged into
like into multiple headboards and also
like a car window
that was like a one-liner zinger looks
so good
it looks good must have been my heck
i think i've had one but i can't
remember
oh god i think it's so cute when you're
like your head is banging up against
something because you know they're just
ramming you so hard so they
they cushion it with their hands yeah
oh you know what's another one on the
list that i thought of just now is when
your hair gets caught on something or on
their own on their own
arm or like on their elbow or something
and i'm like oh yeah
okay i don't want to ruin this for you
but
yeah uh you're scalping me yeah have you
ever um done something that you thought
was going to be hot and then it was just
really annoying and but you didn't want
to ruin the moment oh yeah lingerie
yeah oh for me i don't know
man i'm just like this shit's digging in
in places i don't want it to dig
in oh annoying for you yeah you're just
thinking of that yeah i was thinking of
like something that actually annoyed him
oh no i don't i don't know i was trying
to think of something i thought that was
the question oh
that it you were trying to be sexy but
it just annoyed the guy like i always
thought that like
just talking too much bondage or
handcuffs and stuff like that that was
another one
yeah and then it's like um it hurts
my arm hurts like my arm is dead here
yeah
oh [ __ ] like i can't do like complete
bondage where i can't move because if my
nose starts itching or something
and then you know he'll use that against
you too you won't let me stop
yeah exactly you tickle it more i don't
want to kill the mood like hey can you
scratch me
it's just yeah it's kind of in the
nostril just like in the nostril just a
little bit yeah
down down down have you guys ever done
uh
food with sex like i've done chocolate
for example milk melted chocolate like
you pour it on then you lick it or
something
yeah no but it just ends up being a
sticky ass mess yeah it sounds like a
mess
it was not sexy i think i used the
aerosol cool
cool hands ready whip yeah ready whip
yeah yeah i think that's something that
you watch in movies when you're younger
like this is what everyone yeah i don't
think people really do that
because like it's just difficult because
it just sounds fun like it sounds more
fun when you're younger like
oh you can't i remember i wanted edible
underwear because of that
so yeah like yeah i was just stuck in my
underwear
but then like your your juices get all
over it and it starts melting all the
sugar all over you like [ __ ]
like you're into yeah i tried it if
you're in a bed with that
like you know they have the kind that's
like the the candy necklace yeah but
then there's the other one that's like
the fruit by the foot yeah
underwear yeah i just picture that
getting on the bed and then having bed
lent all over it
or cat hair yeah pet hair or like they
take a bite and they're eating it and
you're like come kiss me they're like
one
yeah they're just chewing them but the
actual the the cord thing that the
those that the candy like this is on
that actual cord have you ever tasted it
yeah it's pretty gross it's [ __ ]
nasty yeah it's like rubber exactly it's
like latexy
like bitter nasty ass tasting i just as
a kid though you just continue to chomp
it because you're getting the candy
around exactly you don't really care as
a kid
yeah i think one time i tried to dress
up
and because i was trying to surprise my
boyfriend when he came back from work
and so i like tried i put on this like
long blonde wig i was i had
my brunette hair at the time and i was
like trying to pretend to be the
babysitter or something and it was just
it i just couldn't pull it off and it
was just so embarrassing so there's that
period of waiting like you're in there
and you're in costume
i was waiting in costume for him to come
home
and i was just like positioned but it's
been like so long
i was like 21 and it was just a total
backfire wait so what happened when he
got home how did you
he was like kind of like still trying to
wind down from works
but then he was like oh she's doing a
thing i gotta like you know be
grateful but it was just like the mood
was just all
wrong it's so embarrassing the trying is
the yeah
embarrassing yeah just don't try my
hardest don't ever try
to way too much my thing was always like
when you're like
you try to move your leg over but it
doesn't go as high you actually kick him
in the face
cause you're not as limber what the [ __ ]
because you're like kicking one in the
face
like a heart trying to like be a
stripper you know like because you're a
missionary
achilles is too hot yeah right exactly
hammy's you're tired
of stretch girl i know right because
like they're hitting him with your legs
on both sides and like
you know i want to do missionary so i
kind of like try to kick it over but
instead
you know but then there are good sports
about it god bless you
i could take up your head it's fine oh
my god it's so funny
i just thought it won but i forgot it
because the head injury
yeah jesus my hand's all [ __ ] up oh
you guys ever feel like during sex like
something
gets caught in your throat you want to
cough oh you don't want to cough
or you got the hair like that's stuck
between the bottom of your tongue and
then the teeth in the very back where
you're like
for me it's coughing like ever have sex
when you're like maybe a little bit kind
of sick or you're getting over a cough
and you don't want to cough in the
middle of it because then you're like
you know like you need that deep cough
to get it yeah exactly
i feel like my body forgets to cough
like i just that like
shuts down rammed into [ __ ] deciding
so i'm getting all of tiff's head
injuries
um no like the hair thing though like
when you when you're
sucking dick and then oh yeah but
there's like
and then you're like
dude you get your own [ __ ] hair is
such a long
area you're just like oh [ __ ] but it's
stuck
it's sticky i think you're trying to
remove it but it's like this
you're like around it
and then your hair's all [ __ ] like
matted because it's covered in slobber
and [ __ ] dick juice you're like oh
it's like there's times when like like
they're hitting it from behind so your
face is in the pillow but if you're a
[ __ ] like me that has false lashes
you're afraid like what if it's like
caffeine at all yeah
and when you turn back around and it's
just like i'm so sorry you know
or like it's like half hanging up like
this you know
what do you do do you just like leave a
room like you put your nose on the
pillow so your eyelashes
uh a half and then i'm just like you
know what [ __ ] it and just take it off
you know well what if we have lash
extensions because those things get all
[ __ ] wonky everywhere
just trying to mine is sometimes i um
there's white we have white sheets
like so we alternate between gray and
white and like if if my face is getting
present like i just [ __ ] clean these
my makeup is getting on them and i just
[ __ ] clean up your face
have you guys ever gotten cramps during
sex yes [ __ ]
usually with that one that i was talking
about the missionary but with the
legs on his shoulders one i always get
cramps on my hips
so i'm like oh crap crap crap he's still
inside but i'm [ __ ] like doing this
[ __ ] but i'm like
sorry yeah he's like helping me too
after a while that being sandwiched in
half that one
definitely gets exhausted that's the
position that i get the most error
sucked in
there too yeah yeah true the most
and then when the legs come down it's
like yeah yeah
like a whoopee cushion
i hate the way it feels i can sometimes
feel that like air gets sucked in but
then he like
recloses it and then he's like oh god
he's like completing a pool float
[Laughter]
you just feel like you're full though
yeah yeah it's like air is like
i'm like i'd rather it come up and i
could burp it then
right exactly i'm not that bad can i
burp my queen
face to burp my queefs out can you push
it further
try a little harder i would like to burp
things better to burp and taste it than
fart and waste it that's
oh my god what that's what my auntie
said why would i
want to taste the thing that's going to
be a fart no that's what happens
no yeah it's better to burp and taste
your food than to fart and then it's
like it's like a shiny thing
that's
you don't like when you eat like tacos
and then later you burp up a little bit
of tacos
two for one deal i love that with
mangoes and pineapple i'm like
yeah something sweet i hate how like
condoms sometimes it just gets dry it
needs to take some time to
put on a new one yeah or like you have
to either keep lubing it up or you
you have to get a new one because it's
going to like tear
understand why we haven't yeah that out
yeah do you guys ever like or even the
guys who like it's
it gets too sensitive that you can't
come that you have to start yeah
for a little bit so just give me a
second like happens to case
yeah it happens during oral for me but
not during sex
hmm it gets a little bit too intense
you're like hold on it's kind of
gonna bring it back down a little bit
yeah yeah i could see that
for guys for sure mm-hmm especially
uncircumcised guys because they're a
little
more plenty
my favorite my i [ __ ] hate when i
have to ride the dick and i'm squatting
on top and my thighs get
[ __ ] come on oh burning yeah i'm like
you've got a solid
six pumps i'm giving you so you better
enjoy this i'm not doing this for
four minutes straight on the ab strength
for this the core strength yeah
i don't like jump going up and down i
like when i'm
on top i'll stay down and then all right
guys hate that though
no he loves that a lot of guys a lot of
guys i i've seen a lot of guys be like
why do girls just grind in circles like
as
if we like that look at steve look at
steve's face
guys like up and down yeah
to circle but also have it go in and out
that's true if you're what i usually do
it takes a lot more work it's like a lot
of work i get it mm-hmm
position because that's how i get to
like hit my right that's true
yes yes the one where you're like as you
go so you kind of hit the top of the
circle it kind of pulls on it a little
bit and then when you go
towards back to the bottom of the circle
it pushes it back in yeah it's still
it's also kind of like going the forward
and back motion yeah yeah my personal
i like the forward and back motion i
don't do circle though it's hard for me
to do that
because it takes a lot of effort but it
the payoff is pretty but
not for the guy i think guys usually
they'll be like oh yeah that's cool no
he tells me to stop because he's gonna
come oh [ __ ] i guess it depends on the
guy
yeah but all right well let us know if
we missed anything put it in the
comments
worst parts of sex most awkward you're
behind a screen name so
go nuts i know we're over here we're
over here
when they don't choke you hard enough oh
yeah or were they when they push on your
windpipe
no no no yeah it makes you want to cough
i i don't like that yeah
i do i like coughing i don't like this
whole coffee don't make tina call don't
make me call
stop it leave her alone all right well
uh we'll we will see you next week be
sure to follow us
on everywhere write us on up these are
our sponsors we need the sponsors
we'll see you next time bye bye are you
pinching their titties they're not
so hard it's